hi my name is the feegan yachty and my
research concerns ways in which to
improve the digital reading experience I
picked up on and came to realize through
my research that part of the reason why
many people prefer to read using print
books as opposed to digital alternatives
has to do with the fact that many of the
useful cues present and print books are
lost when you port over the form and
presentation to digital context on top
of this many people don't actually find
ways in which to take the added
capabilities of digital devices to
improve the reading experience over and
above what is possible using print
alternatives my research basically
concerned combining the the loss and
these added capabilities to come up and
devise a new alternative text
presentation that could aid digital
reading to inform the design of this
presentation I did a bit of background
research on the visual and cognitive
processes that happen during reading and
came to realize three things the first
of which when we read we actually only
read within a specific region within our
visual system called the foveal region
and because we only can read in the
specific region we have to basically
scan the page to pass the words and the
scanning overtime introduces a cognitive
load associated with trying to plan for
the next gaze the second thing is the
human brain can actually process about
four to five and from information units
what this does is it sets a constraint
on the amount of words you can actually
process at a specific given moment
lastly knowing your place within a
document is very important in
understanding where you are which
improves gives you a sense of the
comprehension and building a better
understanding of the text as a whole so
with this information at hand we wanted
to design a presentation that took that
into account but also was benchmarked on
three metrics namely reading speed
reading comprehension
and workload index in an ideal world we
wanted a presentation that would allow
the reader to read at a rate much faster
than without it however not at the
expense of comprehension at the same
time we didn't want this presentation to
be a lot harder to use which would make
it a lot harder for user adoption in a
nutshell what the presentation does is
it presents a set fixed number of words
to the reader over time however at a
rate that is dependent on the words
being presented to assess the
performance of this presentation we
benchmarked it against a standard
reading scroll based text presentation
we're currently running the study so
there's no results at the moment but
we're optimistic about the results